la responsabilité du j'espère ce sera
plus facile à dire et bien la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
et de sa famille donc comme ans comment
cela s'entend la sécurité du président
de la république c'est une sécurité qui
s'exerce à tout moment à tout instant
qu'on soit dans des cadres officiels
comme dans le cadre de sa vie privée
quant à sa famille il est il est fait
une analyse de la menace pour savoir
jusqu'à quel niveau des membres de sa
famille cette sécurité doit s'exercer et
bien sûr c'est aussi dans le cadre d'un
échange d'un échange avec le président
de la république lui-même le j'espère à
mon époque était constitué de 90 à 100
personnels selon le moment tous ces
personnels avaient été sélectionnés par
mois ils appartenaient tous au service
de protection des hautes personnalités
ou au raid unité d'intervention de la
police nationale
concernant l'exercice de cette
protection de cette mission de cette
responsabilité je les dis elle s'exerce
à tout instant pour ce qui me concerne
pendant les dix ans pour lesquels j'ai
eu à m'occuper de la sécurité de nicolas
sarkozy et plus particulièrement les
cinq dernières années quand il était
président la république il n'y a eu
aucune exception à ces moments là
jamais le président de la république ne
m'a sollicité pour que la sécurité ne
soit pas présente à ses côtés
quel que soit le moment quelle que soit
la nature de ce moment encore une fois
que ce soit dans un homme dans un pôle à
l'occasion d'un déplacement officiel
comme alain moment comme à l'occasion
d'un moment privé c'est un lien de
confiance qui doit s'installer avec la
personnalité sans doute pour moi c'était
plus aisée puisque je n'ai pas été
nommée à l'occasion de sa de son
élection mais bien j'ai eu à accomplir
cette responsabilité depuis cinq ans
auparavant ce qui n'a pas toujours été
le cas de deux de mes prédécesseurs de
mesures de mes successeurs